you only have five seconds before the
excuses win
that's it and it has to do with how your
brain is designed
if you want to not procrastinate on
monday
sunday night i want you to sit down and
do this simple little thing
how do you get good at anything you
practice so willpower
self-discipline is a muscle
and if you want to build a muscle you
need to flex it stretch it
go to your edges and practice daily
want to be happy build a life not just a
business
hey it's evan carmichael and this
channel was created to help you overcome
the number one
challenge that is holding you back a
lack of belief in yourself
you watch these videos because you know
there's something greater inside you too
you've got michael jordan level talent
at something so today let's live your
best believe
life and learn the simple brain hacks to
beat procrastination
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one use the five second rule with mel
robbins
if you're in a situation where
you should do something and
the excuses roll in you only have five
seconds before the excuses win yeah
that's it
and it has to do with how your brain is
designed
and so i started seeing this five second
window
everywhere everywhere you walk into a
networking meeting
and the five-second window is right
there because you look around and you
see all these people you should talk to
and you feel yourself freeze
five four three two one and you can
start walking
if you're trying to sell something the
five second window's always there
because you either have a phone you need
to pick up and make a phone call or you
have a person you need to talk to
but instead of doing it that five second
window's right there and the excuses
roll in and then you're not doing it
yep and so we talk ourselves out of it
right after five seconds like why not to
do it all the time
and then it's even more sophisticated
than that is which which is what i
discovered
and what's more sophisticated about it
is that
you have two modes to your brain you
have the prefrontal cortex
which is the mode of your brain it's the
front part of your brain that does all
your strategic planning your decision
making your
not all your decision making that's
wrong it does your intentional decision
making
conscious decision making it's what
you're using when you're acting with
courage it's what you're using when
you are learning anything new if you've
ever taken a standardized test
when you walk out of a standardized test
what do you have you have a freaking
headache because you've been using this
part of your brain
that's the one part the other part is
the interior part of your brain which
automates everything it's where
self-doubt is it's where habits are it's
where
automated decision making is it's where
every negative
[ __ ] [ __ ] that we do it's stuck
right here
so what the five second rule is actually
doing on a very sophisticated level
is it's switching off this part and
awakening
the part that gives you control and so
the problem with our excuses
if you want to get into the brain
science is that if you
start to think and you start to think i
feel tired or i don't want to or i'm too
stressed out or now's not the right time
that becomes automatic and it gets
encoded right here so part of the
problem with our excuses is that when
you stop and think and hesitate
you trigger your brain to automatically
talk you out of it
that's the problem it's not the excuses
it's that your brain
has done it over and over and now it
takes over right so i invented the
world's
um most powerful cheat code for the
brain
one night when i was drunk sitting in my
living room watching television
rule number two discipline yourself with
eric thomas
yo e you got to discipline yourself i
started looking at mother teresa
of gandhi and i was like yo bro gandhi
would go fast from sex
and he was married he would fast from
talking
you know i just started watching these
great people and i was like oh these
people fast and
not about fast and like that's not the
piece but they were very disciplined
people
and they would not allow their exterior
world to dominate or
destroy their internal world i just like
yo i want to get to a place where
i can control me my family members have
grown i lost the uncle who cirrhosis of
the liver
brilliant man but just drinking drinking
drinking
and i was like yo i do not want to my
father was a substance abuser for years
i was like yo i don't want a life where
something else is controlling me
you know like for real when i left home
and said i don't want to be controlled
no more like i meant that
like i don't want nothing to control me
but me and so i got to put myself under
extreme
discipline to make sure i'm free so when
people see me you get up at three you
don't drink you don't smoke
i'm not doing that because i think i'm
better nobody else or i think you're
gonna go to hell cause you had a dream
i just want i wanna control i want
freedom
and for me disciplining myself means
more freedom
and the less i you discipline yourself
people who
uh i told my son the other day i was
like yo son i don't not want you to have
fun
i just seen a history of people who just
have fun christmas
thanksgiving halloween new year
they're the people thursday night friday
night oh man
every night they're the people who end
up in their 20s having a
great deal of fun but in their 40s and
50s
they working for somebody um and i'm not
saying nothing wrong with cleaning
toilets but they doing something they
don't want to do
for the rest of their life and they
can't retire because they played so much
you know so for me i just look at
venison serena michael jackson
when he used to like five and six just
dancing all night
i just think the more man discipline
himself the greater it doesn't mean it's
gonna happen
but the greater the probability that he
has this sense of freedom
rule number three project plan with
brendan burchard
you're more likely to do something if
you have already
prepared and stepped it through
you're already more likely to do
something if you already prepared
and stepped it through what does that
mean it means if you want to
not procrastinate on monday
sunday night i want you to sit down and
do this simple little thing
project plan i know it's not sexy
please don't make fun of me right now
it's not sexy i know it's not sexy
and it will change your life forever the
day before
the days in which it's required that you
really get stuff done i want you to sit
down
and project plan i don't mean tomorrow
write down your to-do lists
that is one element of project planning
but i want a bigger picture i want you
to be thinking about
the big projects that you have coming up
and i want you to have
written out these steps that it's going
to take the big steps that we'll take to
accomplish this project
and this project and this project with a
timeline for each of them
and then work backwards from that to
create tomorrow's to-do lists
but here's what's funny if listen this
if your mind can't see completion
if your mind cannot see completion
meaning you don't know the path
you don't have clarity on the path to
fulfill or complete something
if your mind can't see the steps
your heart will ask to pause
if your mind can't see
the project through the completion your
heart will ask to pause
even if you're the most passionate dream
oriented
amazing high performer in the world but
you yank away someone's clarity
you know no goals no growth
no clarity no change and so if you find
yourself procrastinating
it might not even you might be like but
brandon i hate myself i procrastinate
and i even know the next three things i
should do i go not enough
knowing your next three steps is not
enough
your mind needs to see all the steps
through to completion
and that's what we call project planning
it's not super fun but it's saying okay
this is the big project here are the big
key activities
the big buckets of activities that would
have to happen to get it done
here's the timelines those big buckets
have to happen okay then these big
buckets of activities
those have to be broken down into tasks
and then into
ultimately daily to dose and if we don't
have that like it's just hard to act
when you don't have a complete picture
right you're kind of like uh
procrastinating let me give you a
metaphor
you know uh they've timed people
about how long it takes them to complete
a puzzle
so if i show up at your house and i give
you a big puzzle box and there's 400
pieces in it
and we set it out on your table
and we watch how long different time
periods takes to complete it
you know the fastest most productive
time in which people are putting puzzles
together
the last 20 percent if you've ever done
a puzzle right
you might walk by it three four times
for a couple weeks you don't do anything
you you put a few pieces together
but as soon as the picture becomes a
little more clear guess what you do
you hunker down and you complete it
don't you
that's what's going on procrastination
even if you see the first couple pieces
it's just like if you can't see where
it's going
your your heart will go pause
i'm unsure i'm scared i don't know what
to do
that's just how we think right that part
of our brain
that is trying to protect us that part
of our heart
that says i want to do good i want to
care for other people and do things with
excellence
all of a sudden those are compromised
when we don't do the most basic thing
so if there's an important project
you've been procrastinating in
do yourself the greatest gift i can give
you today
and that is tonight sit down with your
journal and step
it all the way out even if you have to
make it up
even if you're like i'm not sure this is
actually the big activities
it it's not about having the perfect
project plan
it's having one that is completed at
least the knowledge you know now
because then your brain go okay let's
get into this and keep making this thing
better
but your brain won't get into it if you
haven't project planned so this is
really important
what i do to avoid procrastination each
week
is every single sunday for me that's my
sunday review days sunday work days
i'll sit down and i'll literally step
through the entire week of
all the major things on my email or on
my to-do list
i'll think about the bigger projects and
i'll just kind of
step it all the way through and guess
what i enter the weak
more engaged more joyous and confident
because i know what the heck is going on
so if you keep procrastinating i promise
if it's not
lots of worry or it's not you know lots
of randomness
it's you haven't seen it through yet
my friend evan carmichael's book listen
humans are built to serve
some people are built to serve the world
others
want to serve the 25 people closest to
them but in either case humans are built
to serve so if you're not happy right
now
it's because you're not serving enough
you got to pick up this book because
it's so inspiring to remind you that
we're all here to contribute
to make a difference to make an impact
and this is your field guide for that
rule number four think like a high
performer with dan pena
i used to be a big weightlifter and the
uh
but uh the uh i i
i i used what i used to warm up with now
is what i lift now
because i'm you know i'm about 50 weaker
than i was uh back in my heyday uh
20 some years ago um but we have a gym
here
we actually have two gyms uh the um
but um the the kids today
find uh reasons
or they find things to do to really
procrastinate and
not take action it's uh but you gotta
love
or you gotta have a passion for what you
do if you don't you know
um it gets tired alistair cook the great
presenter bbc presenter
told me about i don't know 30 35 years
ago being a professional
being a high performance professional is
being able to do your very best when you
don't feel like it
okay when you don't okay and uh
and and i've had days not every day uh
do i i wanna
speak uh when i'm at the university the
oxford university edinburgh or whatever
but they don't know it as far as they
are concerned i look like you know i was
i was born for that night and uh the uh
and so but i was taught
high performance people don't leave
anything on the stage
yeah and athletic endeavors i never left
anything on on uh
on the field in uh public speaking uh i
don't leave anything on the stage i'm
fully spent
in each day rule number five find your
motivation with tai lopez
most people procrastinate because they
don't feel confident that the what
they're doing really motivates them
if it really motivates motivated you it
would you wouldn't procrastinate
it's like a 14 year old kid that the mom
and dad can't get the kid to do anything
but the kids motivated play video games
kid will ride his bike across town to
buy a video game and come back
like so there's motivation there the
parents just don't know how to find it
and as you grow you have to know how to
find deep within yourself that
motivation and once you have motivation
you have no problem with procrastination
and rule number six the last one before
very special bonus clip
is practice willpower with robin sharma
a lot of people ask me how can i build
world-class willpower
how can i be procrastination simple idea
and you know this
which is how do you get good at anything
you practice
so willpower self-discipline is a
muscle and if you want to build a muscle
you need to flex
it stretch it go to your edges and
practice
daily so how do you become iconic
in terms of self-discipline it's a
practice
and the more you practice the better
it'll get
the more consistent you are the more
masterful you will become
so practicing unprocrastinating
every day will make you legendary
at beating procrastination now i've got
a special bonus clip on how to create a
list that i think you're going to enjoy
but before that it's time for the
question of the day i want to know
where do you need to most practice
willpower
in your life or business let me know put
your answers down in the comments below
and if you made it this far in a video
you're still here watching and you
promise you commit to yourself that
you're gonna take
action we don't just watch videos here
believe nation we do something about it
give me a hashtag believe down the
comments below if that's you
so i can celebrate with you too i want
you
to take a piece of paper out and i want
you to list
the major projects that you want to
fulfill in
a year's time i want you then to
prioritize them one two three and four
then i want you over the course of three
months
finish one project not two not three not
four
don't uh walk away from here without
creating that list and then prioritizing
and then starting now to finish a task
it could be you could start with small
things like starting that list
and if you start the list and you put
four things down guess what
you have completed your first project
give yourself kudos
and then go into the next it's great
doing lighting
[Music]
if you want some amazing affirmations
from mel robbins check out the video
right there next to me i think you'll
enjoy it
continue to believe and i'll see you
there what i'm about to
explain to you is mission critical you
must become a master
at visualization
[Music]